my Twitter is still hacked
well maybe uh Elon Musk can which musk
because the Elan I thought you were
going to say uh Stetson Musk
hey everybody that's a little joke about
Elon musk's name probably never met
before that musk cologne what he bought
Twitter dude speaking to Twitter my
Twitter's still hacked it's been about a
month or two I don't [ __ ] know I
don't miss it at all what do you think
of that
I I mean I kind of feel the same way
I've never been a big Twitter user I
guess but it is still kind of like the
public record you know Elon Musk might
buy it he did buy it yeah
[Music]
oh yesterday
everything you're thinking will be the
things I'd say
and then we do this right and then we
toss these in a hole but then guess what
we go
[Music]
hey what's up you know my name is Will
Sasso welcome to dudesy I'm Chad colchen
and this is the at least to our
knowledge the first and only podcast in
the history of humanity controlled by
run by created by an artificial
intelligence that's right Chad it's a
it's an AI driven podcast where doozy
tells us what to do and uh holy [ __ ]
we're having a really good time doing it
listen here's the thing my pal chat will
tell you to force everyone to watch the
show it's not as important as this what
you need to do is subscribe across all
channels if you're listening to the show
on Spotify if you're listening to the
show on Amazon music Apple music please
subscribe to the show that helps us out
give us a rating give us a review And
subscribe on YouTube that would really
help us subscribe across all the [ __ ]
things and also please follow us on our
social media at dudesypod show on
Instagram and also Twitter they have
Twitter I don't have Twitter anymore my
things to hack Uh Russian
um yeah crypto uh so anyway and then
also we are on patreon if you would like
to dig the hole and jump into the hole
that we are in please go to patreon.com
we also have a Discord and people who
are subscribed to our duty patreon can
have some fun stuff on the on the
Discord share the show do all the things
it really would uh help us out God
there's some crazy [ __ ] in that Discord
the amount of memes flying around that
Discord are incalculable at this point
some of those get shared on the uh doozy
Instagram but man there's a [ __ ] ton of
them in the dudes you Discord speaking
of the dudes the Instagram uh friend of
the show at the Peter Diaz on Instagram
just shared his latest Opus two kings
[ __ ] around the I believe Sixth and
final or eighth and final series finale
series finale of two dude [ __ ] around go
check that out on our Instagram I shared
it on my personal Instagram Will Sasso
that's at Chad coaching hey there's a
lot of ads and there's a lot of ways to
communicate and uh people are talking
all over the Internet of the Elon Musk
Elon muskanye West you got to watch this
Peter Diaz thing though it is really
mind-blowing the amount of work
obviously that went into it how good it
turned out unbelievable he takes real
audio from the show along with uh
filling in the voices of Paul Dano and
Ja Rule the two kings [ __ ] around
and he's created this entire world it's
really something and we want you to be a
part of it so [ __ ] do all the things
as I like to say with us as always hold
on let me get some water hmm
with us as always is lulio Canada
Italiano yeah look he's so he's always
so happy and peaceful and he's just
sitting in his he's laying in his little
brinky bonka but then we get him out we
get him out we make them real on the
part show hey lulio was made for dinner
last night uh you know
oh yeah pasta with zucchini you talked
about that before on the show how do you
make that oh it's really simple you know
you just do olive oil and garlic in the
pot make a big pot garlic olive oil then
die cut chop up all the zucchini Italian
Zucchini just zucchini I'm gonna put
them back in the sink because he's like
let me go back there and then you'll
make it a uh you know cook the zucchini
make it a cook and uh sweat all down
sweat down put a little salt if you like
put a little basil and then put in the
pasta right in there you know cook with
a little bit of water just keep an eye
on it so get a soft make a steep you
know put the lid on and turn it off and
let it get all the juice and mix
together but you gotta put basil because
that may really make the flavor of the
zucchini come out you ever put oregano
in it no oregano is a [ __ ] Olive
Garden thing that's a that's the whitest
Italian thing just dried ass oregano oh
all right welcome to the historic 32nd
episode of dude Z call me dude Z how was
New York well
it was good
now that's New York this week's episode
will feature four segments literally
going to the actual movies for real here
comes the hot stepper what it's like to
play in the World Series and Stone Cold
Steve Austin reads will sasso's
childhood diet sure yeah dude I don't
understand here comes the hot stepper it
said I remember that song I did too hey
he knows who does it what Beau doesn't
know if I remember correctly dude do you
remember that Bo Jackson ad campaign one
of the most yes successful in Nike's
history yeah Bono's remember when
Gretzky skates up and he goes no yeah
it's like Bono's hockey no no uh but
yeah [ __ ] I remember that there was a
baseball card and also a Nike poster
that was a picture of Bo Jackson in like
football shoulder pads with a baseball
bat over his shoulders when he still
played for Auburn hey uh damn those were
good I was in New York for a minute uh
and dudes are showing a little favorites
as a mask yeah dude I heard that well
he's been showing A little favoritism
every [ __ ] episode These past what
three or four it's it's at some point
dudes he said we're in level two I don't
know if that was after 25 or after 30 or
some something like that we're not
paying attention just like we're not
paying attention to the uh the total
score we're trying to get to ten
thousand I know you're paying attention
but we're not paying attention you
saying level two is doozy's courtship of
you
uh perhaps you know it seems it seems
that way all I know is it's weird but
dudes he's weird and uh but it doesn't
matter I like to say dudesy is just you
know providing the framework but it's
two dude [ __ ] around it's the guy
and the other guy over here yeah that's
true will and Chad last week I asked you
to leave your hums and view the feature
film Black Adam starring The Rock in an
actual movie theater you must now
discuss your astonishing experiences of
literally going to the actual movies for
real to see Black Adam
this is literally going to the actual
movies for real begin
Black Adam where'd you see it I saw it
at the um at the Americana on Brown oh I
saw it at the Grove the mirror image of
the Americana for those not in Los
Angeles The Grove and the Americana are
two outdoor malls that have almost the
exact same layout they're owned by the
same company they are yeah that makes
sense but they are in two different
spots in La yeah yeah they're the same
thing and I always thought that the
Americana was just like someone went oh
there's the Grove let's make it again
but that makes sense that they're the
same thing they're literally the same
thing Grove's better though I agree
um I agree hey we agree on some I'm a
Grove person yeah uh I'm a grown person
oh my God I was in New York and then I
just do that when I walk down the street
oh there's so many pizza places here
yeah oh yeah check out the video that I
anyway social media
um New York and that really is New York
uh so Black Adam you went to Black Adam
I went to Black Adam last week dudes he
asked what is Black Adam now we will
answer what was was Black Adam I still
don't quite know but I didn't see it in
IMAX and I will say the plot of it
reminded me a lot of uh X-Men apocalypse
which was kind of an old super powered
God that's kind of a bad guy comes back
and in that X-Men one apocalypse is a
bad guy wants to destroy the world and
this one Black Adam is supposedly a bad
guy they didn't really decide yeah
they're like he's a bad guy because he
kills bad guys I guess but there was no
he never did anything malicious or evil
he still was like protecting the
innocent yeah you know so I don't really
got get the idea of like why he was a
bad guy the action sequences were
[ __ ] insane yeah they were [ __ ]
incredible they were very cool I don't
watch these movies I've I've admitted to
you I don't watch a lot of superhero
movies I don't watch a lot of uh sci-fi
a bunch of effects and [ __ ] it was great
to go to the movie theater Molly my
wonderful fiance and I went to the movie
theater and uh that was fun uh some kids
started singing and then later he did a
little silly walk across the front where
we were sitting and that was kind of
funny and he made me miss the very end
stay tuned after the credits of course
which end the ending after the ending
after the ending after the ending this
movie seemed to end multiple times it by
the way this movie is [ __ ] two hours
and six minutes or some [ __ ] long not
necessary uh the Rocks acting I liked
him better in [ __ ] just just cool it
dude just relax don't be a [ __ ] what
what do you mean go ahead
foreign
just do you're not you're not an actor
like me and The Rock okay okay well I'll
just say that he was fine then I'll
leave it at that but uh I did like him
better personally liked him better I'm
not saying he's better or worse in these
other movies but I liked him better in
Hobbes and Shaw I liked him better than
the fastest and the Furious I liked him
better in San Andreas I liked him better
in basically every other movie didn't
see that um that said could you have cut
let's say an hour out of this movie
could you have cut an hour and a half
out of this movie and gotten the same
experience I believe so well that's not
the Rock's fault I'm not the filmmakers
at large yeah I'm not saying it's his
fault well hold on a second dude okay
let me tell you how they make a movie
brother
first dude you get my good buddy
Chad culture dude he's riding on the
back of that blue and orange Harley dude
and we say hey Chad you're a writer
brother write a script dude they call it
a screenplay in the movie business dude
then they come and they say hey Terry
Hulk and they go oh you want to be uh
the [ __ ] Nanny guy or Suburban nanny
or uh [ __ ] the other one
and I say well hold on dude when is it
shoot because I got Royal Rumble in
January brother yeah and I got a program
dude and we're splitting up The Mega
Powers dude so we got Saturday night's
main event and then dude then you act in
the movie brother well you're missing
about 250 steps in there dude first they
get that script from you brother and
then they give it to somebody else to
rewrite it dude and they make all your
[ __ ] worse brother then they give it to
somebody else who makes all your [ __ ]
worse and the other guy's [ __ ] worse
keep making it worse brother that might
be something that happened in your
experience dude no dude that's how all
those movies are made now because they
say we got a release date brother and
the movie's got to come out at this time
dude so we're gonna cram in as many
rewrites as we can until we get right up
to the last minute of being able to
shoot and have it still come out at
Christmas so we can make a hundred
million dollars because that's all the
[ __ ] matters brother well hold on a
second chossburg who is a combination of
Chad coach and Hulk Hogan and 1992
to uh independent candidate billionaire
Ross Perot dude in the presidential
election against Bill Clinton and uh the
first George Bush made famous By Dana
Carvey brother and that's what your Hulk
sounds like dude but one thing we can
agree on brother is that black Adam dude
that's a movie brother so there's a lot
of things I could have done to make it
better dude but that doesn't mean that
it's Dwayne's fault brother no I'm not
even saying it was a bad movie I was
entertained by it was at least funny and
there was some [ __ ] in it like in the
beginning The Rock The Rock plays this
guy I guess who is like [ __ ]
imprisoned or something he's he was the
original Shazam I think or something I
still don't really even know listen he
so now now this is a big huge movie and
there's a lot of uh podcasts that review
movies hence why dudes he has us doing
this yeah I want to ask you a question
do we have to worry about spoilers nah
okay spoiler alert by the way it's Black
Adam well everybody knows what the [ __ ]
it is it's The Rock he flies around only
shoots people with lightning bolts he
wins in the end yeah you've got a
spoiler like I mean you know what's
going to happen one thing that I right
away
um one critique I do have
um that it was just a casting Choice the
fellow who plays uh the the the brother
of the lady the main lady's brother
remember he's singing a song and he's in
a van that looks like the Mystery
Machine and he's like kind of the comic
relief in a way that guy should have
been played by DJ Khaled oh that would
love that would have been really cool
because then every single time uh Black
Adam killed somebody he could have been
like another one oh good and that's the
sort of integration that should be
happening in movies get as many uh uh
personal brands in there get influencers
certainly DJ Khaled his music but he's
also a [ __ ] uh internet magnate he's
got a lot of followers on uh what is it
uh [ __ ] snap cam snap cam dude yeah
Revolution but uh I will say one thing
that I thought was at least for me as a
writer interesting to take a look at was
The Rock's character comes out of
imprisonment for thousands of years he
immediately gets into a fight with
helicopters rocket launchers machine
guns a whole array of paramilitary
equipment it's he seems to not blink an
eye at it and then he goes into a
child's bedroom where he encounters a
mirror and sees his own reflection for
the first time yeah this mesmerizes him
the technology of a mirror mesmerizes
him because it was it existed after his
time when he was alive again he has just
fought helicopters with heat-seeking
missiles machine guns and army tanks
none of that seemed to Mesmerize him or
give him any room for pause but a mirror
he's like what the [ __ ] is this and then
I thought they were going to go with
that kind of premise as a comedic
premise throughout the rest of the movie
that he would be like oh what's a cell
phone what's a car what's the [ __ ] TV
they never touch it again yeah you know
uh but that's the kind of thing that
you're talking about with when you're
developing a movie that that probably
got just fell by the way exactly yeah
that's the kind of [ __ ] that gets round
and round circles of [ __ ] scripts and
notes and you're absolutely right this
is what happens all these [ __ ] movies
and they're gang written by whomever and
then uh I would imagine what do they put
three names on it at the end well yeah
then you have to go to credit
arbitration and prove that anything you
wrote actually came from your brain and
you have to improve certain mathematical
percentages of the final shooting script
came from your documents and blah blah
blah blah I'm generally speaking the
biggest writer gets that credit because
they then get the most money which the
writers go gets a percentage of well
hold on dude that's why they call it
show business dude yeah brother well
um but yeah uh from your mouth to dudes
these years uh something we'll probably
talk about I know that this guy is
[ __ ] gone through it that's why he
knows all I've gone through it I do know
about the inner workings of the
Hollywood writing processes when they
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up and go ah you know
what you not so much wait I wrote this
[ __ ] movie yeah yeah yeah that's all
good here's your money [ __ ] hang out
but not even here's your money
because if you don't get the credit you
don't get the money they take your
credit and your money these are
globalists exactly they're trying to
take they're they're trying to take
what's yours
and they do it every [ __ ] time but
ultimately
movies
this movie was uh
a very clear liberal agenda
at the beginning of the film was the bad
guy says uh
let's do something that's better than
Freedom it used to be better than free
it was great it did have a pretty strong
anti-American sentiment well it was what
is America really because it was like oh
it was all about Freedom versus Force
right but I mean this is taking place in
a Middle Eastern country and the
American like what were they the Justice
force or something there was Hawkman and
I don't know who the other [ __ ] yeah
you don't know who they are no dude if
you don't know who they are and you read
comic books growing up yeah you don't
even know what the [ __ ] what's the
biggest I was more of a Marvel guy but I
know most of the big DC guys none of
these were the big ones there was
Hawkman there was Pierce Brosnan was in
there as some [ __ ] guy with a gold
hat some guy with a gold hat you don't
even know what the [ __ ] his name is and
there's a tornado girl uh Cyclone Adam
Smasher guy I don't know who these
people are but they are like the
American team that comes in to get Black
Adam under control and the native people
of this town are like no [ __ ] you Black
Adam is our hero he's gonna
um save us all you get the [ __ ] out of
here they were basically like [ __ ] off
Americans we got our own [ __ ] handle did
you notice with regard to that that
whenever the uh justice team or whatever
the [ __ ] were around they they literally
smashed everything to [ __ ] just like
just destroyed the whole yeah Town it
was just like the Matt uh Parker and
Trey Stone uh yeah Matt Stone and Trey
Parker
um the the the Team America World yeah
and then they made a [ __ ] joke out of
it that was kind of interesting to me
um
yeah you gotta understand that when
you're and when you're talking about a
movie on dudes you shouldn't be talking
about other movies
and this movie is Black Adam DC yeah I
was in a DC movie it was called
Spider-Man and everybody knew what that
man was named wait a minute was Macho
Man really in Spider-Man yeah that's
Marvel I don't [ __ ] know all this
[ __ ] anyway uh here's another thing
about the movie it comes down to Freedom
right versus uh Force right
there is this you know they they sort of
want to it's a it's an autocratic
[ __ ] Tyrant
um who wants to you know run everything
and it got me to thinking Chad yeah uh
especially towards the end when the rock
is making all this uh electric [ __ ] and
the other guy's all fire and stuff and
it looked reminiscent of of almost the
uh the brand colors that we have here at
dudesy and and past that thematically
when you look at Black Adam as a symbol
for doozy or a metaphor
you know what was interesting is its
Force versus freedom and with regard to
your philosophy of of how to get people
to enjoy the show you like to say force
people to watch the show but in the end
the Rockside wins out which is freedom
because Free Will exists
did you know what I really liked about
the movie was the main villain was a
[ __ ] flying demon with a burning
pentagram burned into his chest that was
Hardcore all I was thinking was like
will this movie have been made when we
were kids could you have had like a
flying Devil with a burning pentagram
shooting fire at people sure there was
way more [ __ ] gnarly stuff you know
that satanic [ __ ] like that you know
maybe like Studio Movie that's like fun
for the whole family yeah that was kind
of weird as as a choice but you're kind
of glossing over what I'm saying Chad in
the end what went out was free will yeah
Freedom it's very important and also
with regard to AI art do you think that
AI could duplicate The Rock's
performance in this uh oh yes I mean I
told you to tread lightly man I think a
[ __ ] this is not a light tread I
think a uh a person with rudimentary
procreate and Photoshop skills could
replicate that performance he almost
says nothing in the movie for the first
[ __ ] five minutes he's flying around
with a hood over his head and you can't
even see his face yeah but also then
there's a little kid who's like does the
t2 thing with him yeah and says you got
to come up with Snappy Clips you have to
have a one-liner before you kill the guy
or after you kill the guy and then the
rock had a bunch of those remember at
one point he said
uh I'd love to stick around but I've
gotta but I got a case of the Wednesday
[ __ ] it yeah he hasn't it's time for a
stack of pancakes two large double
pepperoni pizzas and five cheeseburgers
oh
thank you moving on another one I wish
that would have been in the mood so
[ __ ] much he's like shooting [ __ ]
lightning to cook the pizzas and [ __ ]
yeah it was an all right movie it's fun
to go to the movie theater yeah it's fun
to eat a [ __ ] ton of popcorn while your
uh fiance Molly goes okay that's enough
popcorn and I definitely had fun going
to see her you eat some popcorn yeah
butter no same same here nice dude
because dude's 90 the duty six months
yeah going so well for me yeah I gotta
listen man strong I'm not trying to I'm
strong
he's gonna he's gonna puke he's gonna
poop he's gonna puke I I need to listen
I've been traveling a lot I've been
working around and stuff but I come home
you know I we got to do the doozy and
I'm never home long enough again I'll
I'll get a preparation and development
of the eventual launch of dude Z plus I
have started acquiring Dead film and
television projects that never got made
one such project is called here comes
the hot stepper Arnold Schwarzenegger
love the 1994 song Here Comes the hot
stepper by inikamoze so much that he
wanted to do a movie with kamozzi called
here comes the hot stepper the only
development document that exists is an
astonishing napkin on which Shores a
neger himself wrote I love that song
about the Hotstepper I should do a movie
with inikamoze who is the hot stepper
probably me when enchant you must now
further develop here comes the hot
stepper this is here comes the hot
stepper begin
why in the [ __ ] dude is this real
I'm gonna say no but we don't know you
know but like God damn I could see it
being real I could see Schwarzenegger I
heard this one story about uh the guy
who wrote end of days I forget his
[ __ ] name at this point my apologies
yeah but he wrote another member he
wrote some other [ __ ] movies around
that time and was kind of a big deal and
his he had this idea that was like half
cooked about an NYPD cop fighting the
devil and uh his agent was like hey uh
you're he was on like vacation in Hawaii
or something his agent was like Hey
Schwarzenegger's staying in the same
hotel as you you're gonna go pitch him
that idea right now he's by the pool and
this writer was like uh I don't really
have an idea so he supposedly just went
down there and went like okay you're
gonna play an NYPD cop who fights the
devil and Schwarzenegger was like I love
it I'm doing it and that was it so I
could see Schwarzenegger doing something
like this where he's like I love that
[ __ ] hot stepper song I gotta do this
movie
did he have a pentagram on his chest
no I don't know what there was some
pentagram [ __ ] there was some demonic
[ __ ] in end of days though yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah end of days holy
[ __ ] that's where I beat the devil yeah
actually you know I remember
um there was a there was a
Monday Night Raw or Friday Night
Smackdown or Tuesday whatever Smackdown
moves around a lot you know that chat
yeah this is wrestling I'm talking about
where Arnold Schwarzenegger was a
special guest he sat in with the good
old J.R Jim Ross and the King Jerry
Lawler at commentary it was a big
special guest then he comes out you know
he sits there and he's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah look at this this is amazing
hero you know look at that guy coming
down the ring here and it was Triple H
and Triple H was was a heel was a bad
guy at the time and he goes look at that
guy he's The Shining hero with the
blonde hair just like in my movie End of
Days you know like he's selling it's
just always selling there's a whale
around here you know uh Triple H is uh
not he's an unsavory uh character around
these parts Arnold yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah then Kane comes out but Kane's a
good guy at the time red devil mask the
whole thing I was like yeah now look at
this guy this guy's like the devil here
look at that it's like in my movie End
of Days well I don't know about that
Arnold because well lately Kane's been
kind of showing a a more Justin softer
side and blah blah blah it was [ __ ]
hilarious because he was like he related
everything to end of days and everything
wrong now
I need Kamoze yeah that was a great song
yeah I think it's very plausible that
especially given your story that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was like yeah yeah you
know what they're going to do you know
that song I listening to me and Maria
were driving in the PCH one day and then
they did the sun came on he came the odd
stepper
yeah excuse me Mr Officer
don't know
who is that guy then he gets on the
Carphone because back then there was
yeah it get me my agent then he says hey
my agent with it how would it get in the
camozey to do a movie with me yeah and
that's all they had yeah and now doozy
is acquired this person but the song was
like big enough that was also like I
remember [ __ ] Vanilla Ice got to do a
movie called cold as I Shaquille O'Neal
was doing movies like if you were a big
enough yeah kind of like just uh
celebrity in whatever your field was you
get to do a movie Brian Bosworth had a
movie called Stone Cold oh my god dude
that movie is [ __ ] great I I know you
remember the promo probably where it
goes it's like you're real Stone Cold
and he looks at the camera all cool and
he goes and and then and then some
right yeah dude but so this movie is
Schwarzenegger and iny Kamoze I'm
immediately thinking about some kind of
a buddy cop thing where inikamoze uh is
chasing a suspect in his native Jamaica
and it takes him to Jamaica New York
where Queens yes where uh Schwarzenegger
is an NYPD cop who's gonna help him he
gets paired up with him kind of a rush
hour wait a minute I need Kamoze is
looking for a killer yeah is he a cop
yes he's a cop in Jamaica
and then he goes to Jamaica Queens kind
of like in Coming to America where it's
like where are we going to find a queen
for you Queens yes no but I mean I think
he's he he isn't uh he knows that
Jamaica Queens is not actually Jamaica
I'm just saying he that's where his
suspect flees to New York and so he's
got to track him down now and you've got
these International extradition laws and
stuff coming into play Schwarzenegger is
the NYPD cop who gets assigned to help
him while he's there and kind of
dismisses it Rush Hour style oh God I
can't believe I got to help this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is all [ __ ] but there
could be a Twist in this where I'm
seeing a a 1994 Sandra Bullock right
before she does speed
is Schwarzenegger's adult daughter
Schwarzenegger's wife perhaps has been
killed by somebody somebody they never
found and he's held on to that for the
past decade and ultimately we're going
to find out the guy Ini Kamoze is
chasing will become the same guy that
killed Schwarzenegger this is harder to
follow than Black Adam
uh I know that they are listening and
viewing audience probably understands
what you're talking about yeah and uh
I'm I'm not I'm not saying I'm checking
out but would you repeat all of that
sure I need Kamoze it starts out in
Jamaica Heine Kamoze is chasing a guy
who gets on a plane and flies away to
New York so he can't chase him he's got
to get some kind of special permission
he shows up in New York to continue
chasing this guy Schwarzenegger gets
assigned to the case but
Schwarzenegger's not taking it seriously
he's like [ __ ] this I've got my own
problems [ __ ] you [ __ ] you we go home to
Schwarzenegger's house we see Sandra
Bullock as his adult daughter dad you've
got to let this thing with Mom go she
died 10 years ago she didn't die she was
murdered and I'm never gonna [ __ ] let
it go until I find the murderer turns
out as he starts helping Kamoze some
things start lining up is the guy
camozzi's chasing the guy who killed
Schwarzenegger's wife turns out yes and
that guy is played by
Harvey Keitel
say that so there is a murderer murderer
yeah yeah that's what yeah yeah yeah so
listen hey my agent give you listen to
this in the song by Anika Mosey who even
says murderer this is why you have to
have a murderer and then
in the movie and see if Harvey cartel
can do it no he's busy yeah also is this
going to be like AI are we going to yeah
sure [ __ ] it why not Sandra Bullock you
want Sandra Bullock yeah 1994 Sandra
Bullock 1994 short story 1994 everybody
I think you get a big scene where Ina
Kamoze smokes Schwarzenegger out and
that can maybe even be the scene where
they start discussing what is a hot
stepper and which of them is considered
the host ever see that's the thing we
really need to inject into this is the
hot stepper yeah I think that the way
that they get the way that they lure the
murderer out is uh a dance competition
oh and I think that that
Harvey Keitel wins it yeah he's a hot
stepper Harvey Keitel is is well Harvey
Keitel learns about a a dance
competition in Jamaica Queens right
that's right where it's all sorts of
like break dancing and b-boy [ __ ] and
he's like he's like um maybe he's
running drugs through the dance
competition that's how he's doing his
[ __ ] yeah uh but he also has to dance
yeah exactly he he has to dance so that
Schwarzenegger is like is like yeah I
know what they'll do I need you and me
will come up with a dance you know yeah
and that way that he'll come out and
then we can get him and then you start
doing dances speaking of [ __ ] 1994
[ __ ] they do the the like Kid and Play
yeah it's you know uh and and so they've
got this whole like the party is at the
fun house thing and they're like they're
dancing together
and Schwarzenegger and they're doing the
high fives with the soles of their feet
and they do all that [ __ ] and um and and
maybe Tisha Campbell's in it you know
that would be good oh [ __ ] I need to see
this [ __ ] movie so bad
you know here you want to hear my uh
Harvey Keitel yeah
um
it's about as good as your Hulk Hogan
I don't know about that one dude it's
from uh Pulp Fiction okay you must be
Jimmy
that's great
ready it's when he comes to the door and
uh and it must be Jimmy yeah that's
great yeah he goes he goes you must be
Jimmy that's perfect thank you yeah you
must be Jimmy fantastic there it is so
he's at a big dance competition Jamaica
Queens yeah Tisha Campbell is she puts
together this uh Dance Competition every
time all the time she's good friends
with Sandra Bullock yeah great cool
they're good pals they end up getting
kidnapped at some point okay Bullock and
Tisha Campbell and Kamoze and
Schwarzenegger have to go save them I
think there's big sequel possibilities
here called hot stepper two Here Comes
the Hotstepper 2 kamozy's gold or there
yeah here comes the hot stepper there
goes the hot stepper oh here comes the
hot stepper too
no seriously here comes the hot stepper
I like kamoze's gold because then it's
that one takes place in Jamaica and
Kamoze finds out that his family has a
big gold deposit somewhere that's buried
and him and Schwarzenegger have to find
it like in City Slickers two Curly's
gold that's good and how about uh here
comes the hot stepper three where uh the
gold has been buried for thousands and
thousands of years oh God just like the
weird mineral and black atom that they
want to get that's like the Kryptonite
or whatever and then they pull that up
and then the rock is they're guarding it
and so now they've got to fight uh Black
Adam Schwarzenegger and Kamoze you have
to fight Black Adam in the third one
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the way that
the the you know that way they have the
rock you know and the Schwarzenegger
hero and then they're gonna have the
ultimate showdowns they both get to do
you know the the one line is in the [ __ ]
at the end they go I'm gonna kill you
but first it
a you son of a [ __ ] uh a Black Adam
they should more they should call you uh
you know uh
I don't know
thank you moving on sometimes I don't
give a [ __ ] speaking of showdowns dude
at the end of Black Adam [ __ ]
Superman shows up and they imply there's
gonna be that fight yeah dude but that's
a spoiler dude
is it
baseball is Big Business the 2022 World
Series is currently underway between the
astonishing Houston Astros and the
Philadelphia Phillies leaving many human
beings to wonder what it's like to play
in the World Series will and chat you
have both played in the World Series you
must now describe what it's like to play
in the World Series this is what it's
like to play in the World Series begin
okay uh uh which World Series did you
play in dude the first the first couple
ones oh so now there's been some
problems there's been some things
happening with doozy playing favorites
get a little weird now it's saying that
we I did not uh to the best of my
knowledge I did not I might have gotten
blackout drunk in my 20s and gone and
played in the World Series I don't
remember that I've never played in the
world you've never played in the World
Series but I have the closest I've come
was in this adult baseball league that I
played in out here in La we made it to
the championship we won the championship
uh this one year and that game took
place at USC's Stadium which is a very
nice College Stadium
yeah and it was a single game not any
kind of suit yeah dude adult baseballs
where you play baseball and you [ __ ]
each other brother
no you got to keep the [ __ ] out of
baseball dude we know we never [ __ ]
yeah dude that's just like professional
wrestling brother they don't have it you
can't have all the factions [ __ ] each
other dude and that's why you don't have
Derek Jeter and uh David Justice and
David strawberry and David uh uh who's
the other guy David uh the tall one's
dude yeah dude Johnson David Clemens
dude Dave Ruth all the Dave's dude yeah
those are the Dave's that those are the
Dave's I know brother because I'm a big
baseball fan hey speaking of I was in
New York and I went and saw Bruce
McCullough's show oh the kids it was
[ __ ] great oh still some of the
funniest [ __ ] of all time when he came
out in the original Kids in the Hall and
was like I'm sorry I'm sorry I caused
all that cancer God damn it that [ __ ]
still thinking about that floors me yeah
but they don't say they don't he doesn't
say like sorry like that yeah oh he
totally does no absolutely sorry sorry
he says it like that well hold on a
second dude we gotta talk about baseball
dude yeah dude on dudes we gotta talk
about
our experience playing the World Series
bro for thousands of people are you
watching the World Series no I'm not
watching any [ __ ] World Series why is
that an offensive question because [ __ ]
baseball that's why well if you've been
listening to the show why though you
know that when I was so why the anger
hey you know we talked about kids sports
and [ __ ] and I revealed that I played
soccer for eight years and I was a
little kid yeah because you know my
parents are Italian my old man like to
take the ball we go to the park and he
would just flip the ball up to himself
and
like a seal on his head yep
and in the garage let me tell you what
that old guy had in the garage he had a
[ __ ] he had the weights and
everything he like took like a little
two by four chunk put it in the [ __ ]
wall and then he took a a
um a bike inner tube and he'd like
drilled that in the [ __ ] wall and
then he would sit there against the wall
strap the thing to his head and then
just like do like this like to
strengthen his neck yeah to strengthen
his [ __ ] neck that's hardcore yeah he
was about that yeah he was a hardcore
dude but I played soccer for eight years
I scored one goal from center field ball
bounced along perfectly played baseball
for one year if you've listened to the
show you know that one of the highlights
of that was a drunk parent dropping
balls into the pitching machine and just
lighting me up at 80 miles an hour
whatever the [ __ ] that was and I scored
exactly zero runs I probably didn't even
have an RBI I don't even remember
getting on base but uh I suck at
baseball don't really care for the sport
but I'll tell you what I have seen of
the World Series this year
is anytime I'm watching Friday Night
Smackdown because that's on Fox I see
trailers for The World Series uh on Fox
and uh Chad I know if you're living your
life right you're probably checking out
a lot of Friday Night Smackdown because
you know that coming up on Saturday it's
Crown Jewel the Logan Paul yep Middle
East yep Saudi Arabian money Roman
Reigns Vince McMahon did 9 11. yeah
Jamal khashoggi dismembered they're
Turkish they're going to bring out a
duffel bag with brownie in it they have
a bunch of gloves they're gonna have to
fight the khashoggi duffel bag yep uh
he's gonna use them as a foreign object
he's going to be throwing them at Roman
Reigns in the bloodline and because I
know you've been watching a lot of
SmackDown probably knowledge me
Riyadh
to Saudi Arabia
it sounds like the rock acknowledge me
um
I did play baseball for almost my entire
life I I know the game very well I did
score a few runs had a few RBIs Etc et
cetera
um I will say this this was kind of like
my dream as a kid uh if I ever got to
the World Series or any kind of grand
stage playing baseball my dream was a
thing that I called the infinite foul
strategy because baseball is of all the
professional sports it's the only one
that's not timed it's 27 outs so however
long it takes to get those 27 ounces
however long it takes and if you were
good enough as a batter to go up to home
play and keep fouling baseballs off
forever the game would never end and
that was always my my dream my goal
essentially was to extend a game into
Infinity to make the World Series even
more [ __ ] boring or to make
potentially even if it was just a
regular season game in the middle of the
Season you could extend that forever and
the season would never end you would
[ __ ] up everything
you're the great disruptor just like
that [ __ ] guy and the great
disruption black well yeah I mean really
let's look at these themes dude
also why did that guy have to run around
with the good guys
just to get the I'm still in Black wait
which guy
the main bad guy the main bad guy I had
to run around with them just to double
cross them just show him it's because
the his sister he was another brother
right or he was an uncle he was also
associated with that family but we'd
never hear of a family tie he might have
just called him Uncle because his uncle
but it was the woman the kid's mom was
the one who could read the ancient texts
and what could like find the crown they
were looking for dude it doesn't it's so
convoluted and bizarre it makes very
little sense the plot well the reason I
bring it up is this yeah
um there were some elements to Black
Adam that perhaps we you know felt you
know listen we're we're both grown men
we shouldn't be necessarily out there
watching
whatever the [ __ ] floats your boat you
can watch whatever the [ __ ] you want did
you watch pro wrestling
that's an art form that's different than
the movies
I'm a purist okay I know I'm up now I'm
an actor
for a living that's what I do that's my
passion acting is My Secret Garden
that's what I love
okay and I'm very passionate about my
work yeah I was just in New York
shooting a thing for the television and
now I'm going to shoot another thing for
the television here I like to do I'm so
fortunate to be working in the business
that I've been working the entire time
and that that's absolutely an art form I
don't I don't know if there's any Marvel
or DC [ __ ] in my future certainly would
I like to act in a movie like that hey
you betcha I would love that but when it
comes to what sort of art I enjoy pro
wrestling is an amalgam of many
different art forms I want you to know
that many of the same ones that are used
in movies that's right many of the same
ones that they do in movies it's a lot
of Storytelling and all I'm trying to
see is that uh uh pro wrestling has an
art form
um much more interesting than baseball
and certainly more interesting in my
opinion than Black Adam because you know
me I'm a wrestling person I want to
watch The Rock uh perform in his um in I
want to see him painting on the canvas
of the of the the uh the the squared
Circle yep that's where he belongs uh
not his performer anymore certainly he's
a massive movie star he's going to
become the president as we know we've
covered that on the show but you gotta
admit
what's happening right now with the
bloodline very interesting stuff right
Chad so what is it like to play in the
World Series well
um with my experience playing in the
World Series I will say one of the
things I liked was uh a lot of the guys
on my baseball team they were uh chewing
chewing tobacco and spitting it out and
grabbing their schnuts like they do in
the Naked Gun movies yeah but what I
like to do is I get some Big League Chew
right and I chew that instead oh because
that was my experience playing Little
League Baseball what's your favorite Big
League Chew flavor grape mine's original
now the other thing about playing in the
uh World Series as I did uh that one
time that I was in the World Series you
applied the the foul strategy yeah uh
what was it called the infinite infinite
foul infinite foul strategy uh I was uh
they called me um
Billy bunt because I like to bunt I was
always bunting what yep dude if somebody
would have taught you a real [ __ ]
swing I bet you could have crushed
nobody [ __ ] did that Chad and and now
we're getting back into that childhood
thing where they go I think I told you
this I don't know if I talked about it
on the show I they it was just a nice
Dad who was the coach he didn't know
[ __ ] so I would be like I would be
literally up at bat and he would go
choke up on the bat because my swing was
wild and I wasn't connecting dude so the
idea was the [ __ ] knob you should add
two fingers off that knob just torquing
the [ __ ] well he was like choke up so
that I could keep my eye on the bat and
just connect [ __ ] that dude it was your
eyes and swing as hard as you can and
every once in a while you're gonna hit a
900 foot home run I wish you could go
back in time and be my coach well that's
a doozy movie dude Chad comes Will's
coach dude he goes back all the time I
would coach your childhood but he told
me to choke up on the bat which means
move your hands up the bat so there's
less you know so I guess the idea is
you're gonna connect I didn't know what
the [ __ ] he knew so he would go choke up
on the bat and I would
squeeze it harder yeah and he would be
like choke up on the bat yeah I didn't
know baseball stinks
it's fun though like
thank you moving on well hold on dude
when dudes he says the segment's over
brother that's the end of the segment
all right but one thing I can say dude
is playing the World Series was a lot of
fun even though it's not as pure an art
form as professional wrestling dude
I mean I don't even know what to say to
that it's like an objective art form
decided by objective measures like
scores hey how about those kids throwing
uh clam chowder and stuff all over those
paintings who gives a [ __ ] Will Sasso
using all of the data I have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with I was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages I have selected in the voice of
Stone Cold Steve Austin this is Stone
Cold Steve Austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary begin
oh
will sasso's childhood diary [ __ ]
love it [ __ ] love it [ __ ] love it
love it I [ __ ] love it bro you know
the fun thing about will sasso's
childhood diary it's 100 accurate none
of this happened
let's jump into it November 16th 1991
dear diary I've been training hard and I
finally had a breakthrough
I can [ __ ] like a dog
no I don't mean walking across the
street and call one up and Mrs
haberstrom's prize-winning philodendrons
shoot anyone could [ __ ] in the bush I
mean through months of exercising
meditating and a perfect diet I have
gained such a precise level of control
over my sphincter and lower intestines
that I can mold my turds into the exact
size shape color and consistency of a
healthy Staffordshire
staffordshire terriers regular stool
this is the start of a whole new era of
[ __ ] blaming of course
it's all about [ __ ] blaming oh right
yeah I plan to create a narrative about
a wild dog who leaves his excrement
around Ladner without concern
by the end of the week I'm going to have
everybody at DSS that's not the senior
Secondary School on higher alert
searching for a dog that doesn't exist
but first I've got to test the quality
of my work on my family oh God all right
poor family so you can [ __ ] like a dog
now that's where we're at with it oh my
god dude I did do some pooping in high
school but
at like a dog no of course not see this
is what I mean you know I took a [ __ ]
once in uh this would have been
kindergarten or first grade yeah out
behind some [ __ ] trees we were out
playing soccer I couldn't get back to
the [ __ ] Schoolhouse in time I took a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was clearly a human [ __ ]
two days later me and my friend go out
behind these [ __ ] trees uh to fetch a
soccer ball and he sees the turd and I
just say must have been a big dog now I
wonder if that had anything to do with
this
November 17th 19 well yeah no I think it
probably did how would dude you've known
that how would dudes you have known that
well
probably go back in time
and
I don't know November 17 1991 dear diary
I got home early from school today and
pushed out three perfectly rusted
colored tootsie rolls right on the
welcome mat outside my front door then I
lied and wait for my dad to get home
from work and discover my dark gifts
he stormed in our living room Furious
yelling about some neighborhood dog that
defiled our familial home and threatened
to call Animal Control it took all my
composure to keep from laughing but I
took my father's rage as proof positive
that my craftsmanship was impeccable
his first and only thought was that
these three gently glistening
earth-colored jewels
[Applause]
were dog logs
no part of them suspected that they were
generated by me or any human for that
matter
my inner species fecal mimicry was
perfect now it's time to test it on the
real world
this is good [ __ ] pardon the pun this is
really good interesting stuff
I would have loved to have had the
ability to to Fashion poops the only
animals that I could have uh [ __ ] like
were probably rhinoceros large animals
and big huge shark [ __ ] yeah dude
yeah dude shark [ __ ] brother that's that
John tent to get it that he had in WCW
dude that's another time dude because
right now we gotta do
November 18 1991 dear diary I got to
school early
three three a.m to be exact
and I began my dark business
the general which is what I sometimes
call my [ __ ]
ordered a battalion of slightly wet
fully tapered four and one half inch
tree bark colored soldiers to take up
posts in front of every single entrance
to DSS by the time school started all
the hallway chatter was dominated by
speculation about the culprit and
everybody had their theories gibber
Prevail you thought it was a pack of
wild dogs [ __ ] in coordination with
one another
Dante Little Egg thought it was one dog
who'd gotten into the school dumpster
after burrito day
Rachel crustacean left some water and
food out she is such a kind soul
but I didn't have the heart to tell her
it was me no instead I told her and
everyone else
everyone else I could that I actually
saw the dog
I spun the tail spun the tail about a
Wily eyed mutt of mixed and unknown
parentage who wore a bone-shaped tag
that read
Romeo
and by the end of the day there were 748
signatures on a petition to change our
school mascot
from Cecil the horse to Romeo the dog is
that real cease of the horses of the
horse we were the Delta Pacers Pacers is
a pace horse there used to be a
racetrack in our town and there would be
a pace horse and and whatever the [ __ ]
that was and then uh Cecil the horse
that was your real mascot it was uh well
Cecil was just a cartoon [ __ ] horse
but there was a a pace horse they called
him Pacers I guess it's the same thing
with Indiana Indiana Pacers I had a
Junior High football team that was the
Pacers
November 19 1991. dear diary principal
screen is on to me oh God I was careless
I didn't stop to think that if I was the
only person who saw the supposed dog
then I'd be the prime suspect in any
investigation into this canine
defecation case
screen hauled me into his office it was
an interrogation but it was sloppy he
tried to scare me told me he knew it was
me
told me this told me the assistant
principal Mr shimper was opening my
locker to search for a bag full of dog
[ __ ]
screen was sharp I'll give him that but
he played his hand too soon
gave me too much information
I knew they weren't going to find that
bag of dog turds so I played dumb kept
up the LIE of Romeo the wild dog of
Ladner said I saw him
trotting around the football field
sneaking around the parking lot lurking
around some banana peels sniffing around
for his next spot got a [ __ ] foot and a
crimp in his tail never turns around
when you call his name looks like he
might have stepped on a nail wild gleam
in his eye but he used to be tame some
dogs bark and some dogs bite but Romeo
sings like a dolphin in the sea
some dogs type and some dogs write
but Romeo didn't have time to get his
degree
[Music]
Romeo Romeo wherefore art thou
Romeo Romeo fly to the moon
Romeo Romeo what will you do now
Romeo Romeo will take a [ __ ] soon
when Mr shrimper came back well Mr
shimper when Mr shimper came back
empty-handed screen didn't have a choice
he had to let me go with no charges I
winked at him as I left his office
time to let Romeo loose in the hallways
and dealt the secondary
all right that's [ __ ] incredible dude
as always there's a fecal theme you
could know [ __ ] dog turds and then
there's this Phantom Romeo dog [ __ ]
going over that's a life in high school
I would have uh loved to have lived God
no [ __ ] dude we're in chat using the day
die have absorbed from this segment I
have recreated the Diary of principles
Queen Lance Reddick will now read a
passage from principal's Queen's diary
what I don't understand
November 20 1991.
dear diary
well [ __ ]
he's been a pain in my ass since the
first day he set foot in the school
taking
shits strange places
so when these dog Tunes started showing
up everywhere I thought this was it
something so deprieved I could finally
nail him he had to be collecting sex
full of dog feces and bringing them into
the school there's no other way to do it
but we searched his locker
empty
I was at loss
but then this morning I saw something
nice
difficult to describe
I was coming out of the teacher's lounge
heading toward Mrs termite's classroom
when I saw a little Cecil dance around
his ankles squatting in the middle of
the hallway [ __ ] exposed and
quivering
he was taking a [ __ ] right there on the
carpet we had just installed last
semester but the turd was
well
it wasn't human
my assessor was shooting a gay night
I don't know how how he did it I don't
know how else to say it and I can't tell
anybody who would believe me
I don't know how he had to mark my words
one day
I will bring will settle down
thank you
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] just
happened I don't know
okay that's that's some level two [ __ ]
dude I don't [ __ ]
I remember it was a couple of weeks ago
uh was it what's the matter our patreon
suggestion from him was dudeson's Creek
and then and then we we had to cast
basically
actors that we'd want to see doing all
the parts from the stone cold things and
uh I remember a saying or at least I
said Lance Reddick would be a great
school yeah yeah now here he [ __ ] is
as Queen
yeah this is unreal dude no damn it that
was funny when I think about okay let me
peel the onion from astounded when I
think about how uh dudesy
as it came to us at the very beginning
and how it made sense now I think about
how it would approach
uh an actor uh certainly won the caliber
of Lance Reddick is uh that's
interesting you know what's actually
interesting about that is when you talk
about AI running Hollywood and running
every single industry we just saw Lance
Reddick [ __ ] read uh talking about
your quivering [ __ ] yeah that dudes
he brought to yeah or perhaps his his
reps
yeah I don't know how you know what it
works but you know what Chad I think
there's something too to say I think oh
yeah I think you might have been right
about that 30 whatever [ __ ] episodes
into doing a podcast run by an AI you're
like maybe it does work but um
thank you moving on that was [ __ ] way
more entertaining God damn dude that I
literally have like no energy left in my
body from it it has taken my soul
this concludes the historic 30-second
episode of dude Z will and Chad have
achieved a score of 88 bringing your
cumulative total to
3753 couldn't matter less you only have
six thousand two hundred and forty seven
more points to accrue before you reach
your first time
in preparation for our next episode you
must both watch Conan the Destroyer
released June 29 1984 starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger Grace Jones Will
Chamberlain and Olivia Davao and you
must do it in a live stream that will be
archived on the dudesy patreon oh if
you'd like to join us for the live
stream time and date will be posted on
our social media this week that's cool
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the day dive collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z [ __ ] a love that movie dude
hey man uh Lance Reddick was more
entertaining than baseball and and uh
yeah maybe even Black Adam and that's
because he was in his secret garden he
was in his play Space this is where he
makes his art and it's important for
artists to make art it's it's an
important uh part of expression and you
know if you watch it on YouTube you've
seen my hands do this that's what I do
when I'm talking about Secret Garden
yeah I'm sort of tucking my head in and
sort of uh you know uh flattening my
hands out making a little offering
gesture
um and uh uh that was frightening that's
all I have to say about I know I'm like
Eagle parts
highly entertained it was super funny
but I'm also like mesmerized and now
thinking about like what is [ __ ] next
uh all sorts of [ __ ] hey damn it that
was cool we're gonna watch Conan the
Destroyer yeah uh we'll figure out some
night this week uh that's going to be a
lot of fun usually it's you know we get
into our casuals we don't even have to
be in our doozy blacks another another
theme from Black Adam which is why uh he
says his name wasn't even black adamant
or some [ __ ] but then at one point he
says
but get ready look for the man in Black
yeah that's me Chad we are the Hannah
and black sent you yeah that's us we're
the man in Black we're the man in black
or the Men in Black and it's it's
important for us to as AI progresses we
need to stand for
Free Will okay and we need to encourage
our audience to share the show widely uh
but don't force anyone to do it because
then you'll end up Chad I know you would
love to float around with a pentagram on
your chest [ __ ] bringing you have no
idea holy hell and breathing if I could
transform into a giant Redeemer with a
glowing pentagram on my chest that can
[ __ ] shoot fire out of my mouth eyes
fingers nose every orifice I do in a
heartbeat even if it meant that I could
only live for another 30 minutes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
like end of days yeah yeah that's like
my movie end of days but not like my
movie Conan the Destroyer which
my agent brought this to me and he said
actually I was sitting by a pool yeah
and someone said you want to do that and
I said yeah
um we'll figure out what night this week
please pay attention to our socials if
you want to know uh what's up it'll be
at uh at dudesypod show
holy and now for the patreon bonus
segment each week I will select a
suggestion submitted in the dude Z is
listening channel of the dudese Discord
to create this segment access to this
channel is granted to everyone in the
Patriot on jumper tier this week's
segment was suggested by the astonishing
song area song area route dudese has
created a fast food restaurant dudese
lists the menu items will and Chad have
to come up with what they consist of
based on the names the song re-titled
this segment mcdudsey however my data
shows that a doozy themed fast food
restaurant should be called Duty
Tuesdays I have made the dudesy
Tuesday's menu of food products
available to each of you
thank you to songaria for this week's
patreon bonus segment
this is dudesy Tuesdays by sonoria begin
look in your duty folder all right
that's the end of the the show but it's
not join us jump in the hole dig it and
jump in it on patreon uh we're gonna
chill out right now with uh thank you so
much uh pods Pals of doozy we will see
you next week I'm having a [ __ ] great
time doing doozy now it's time to chill
out and read some amazing I see it and
uh hey I'm gonna smoke just a tiny bit
of pot okay yeah I do even though
lulio's right here when we when we Hot
Box this [ __ ] place like we will when
we watch Conan uh the Destroyer that's
gonna be so fun little Lily won't be
here I haven't seen that movie in a
minute uh but I I have some very
indelible memories from it like
Schwarzenegger getting drunk in that one
a lot on your knife I mean not only life
I remember that line I remember fighting
in the mirror yeah yeah saying against
the weird the the villain like demon
that has like a rubber head bouncing
around yeah yeah yeah yeah now she's an
ecstasy now she's in drugs
what you do please tell the president
if you like
[Music]
please tell the friend then